en parler nous sommes avec bertrand
soubelet ancien général de corps d'armée
numéro trois de la gendarmerie nationale
bonsoir bertrand soubelet avec nous en
direct sur arte france qu'elle va être
précisément le rôle de l'armée dans ses
mesures de confinement pour l'instant
leur vie va continuer d'accompagner les
forces de l'ordre comme elle l'a fait
jusqu'à présent dans l'opération
sentinelle c'est l'essentiel de leurs
missions pour l'instant vous avez noté
que dans l'est de la france
le service de santé des armées s'est
déployée à déployer à l'hôpital de
campagne et c'est probablement la plus
forte action désarmé au service de nos
concitoyens
pour ce qui concerne les contrôles ils
vont être faits comme ils le sont
habituellement par les forces de l'ordre
les policiers en zone urbaine et les
gendarmes dans le reste du pays et selon
des modalités qui ont été définis et qui
semble pour l'instant
j'allais dire plutôt souple parce que il
faut un petit temps d'adaptation et puis
ensuite le premier ministre a déjà
indiqué ça sera un tout petit peu plus
un peu plus compliqué et les gens seront
davantage confiné et il faudra qu'il ait
effectivement qu'ils sont porteurs de
cette attestation voir circuler vous
venez peut-être de nous révéler un
élément important
le premier ministre semble dire
effectivement qu'il y aura un
confinement plus important non il sera
pas plus important il simplement
ils demandent à ce que les les consignes
qui ont été données jusqu'ici soit
appliquée le plus le plus précisément
possible par l'ensemble des français
je pense qu'un effet on ne pourra
ralentir la propagation du virus que si
chacun d'entre nous se conforme
strictement aux consignes qui ont été
données par le gouvernement ces derniers
jours aujourd'hui donc premier gens de
confinement est ce que les français
d'après vos remontées du terrain semble
avoir joué le jeu est ce qu'ils ont pris
la mesure effectivement la gravité de la
situation ce qu'ils étaient on a
beaucoup commenté évidemment pas
beaucoup le cas le week-end dernier
oui des éléments dont on dispose ce soir
déjà ce l'ensemble du territoire
national dans les villes comme dans le
reste du pays les français ont appliqué
les consignes et semble désormais
réaliser la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes
qui est une situation extrêmement grave
ce plan sanitaire
quoique jusqu'à présent beaucoup de
personnes ont cru que ça allait être
comme une grippe habituelle que nous
connaissons chaque année eh bien non
c'est une crise sanitaire extrêmement
grave et qui nécessite de la discipline
individuelle chaque jour et pour au
moins pour les 15 prochains jours qui
s'annoncent alors vous l'avez mentionné
un l'intervention évidemment de l'armée
en alsace on repère nous en parler
effectivement il ya quelques instants
aussi comment se montrent un hôpital de
campagne par l'armée
c'est une chose aisée c'est quelque
chose qui est voilà comment dirais-je
très codifié chez vous parce qu'on
imagine que c'est pas tous les jours
forcément avait goûté vous savez le
service de santé des armées et d'un
service qui fonctionne 365 jours par an
vous avez des hôpitaux de campagne qui
sont montés régulièrement au cours des
opérations extérieures que mène les
troupes françaises à l'étranger
ici en france il y a aussi des exercices
chacun sait exactement ce qu'il doit
faire et le montage de l'hôpital de
campagne était une manoeuvre
parfaitement bien organisée
chacun sait ce qu'il a à faire ça ne
pose aucune difficulté et ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est j'allais dire
improvisé c'est tout à fait c'est tout à
fait bien organiser les choses sont tout
à fait claires il n'y a aucune
difficulté une campagne ça se monte
j'allais dire globalement en quelques
dizaines de est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
y aura d'autres hôpitaux de campagne
destinée est remonté en france en tout
cas je sais qu'il ya une capacité de
montée
eto'o de campagne ils le seront si les
nécessités de la crise sanitaire
l'imposent ici ou là pour l'instant
manifestement il n'en est pas question
mais chacun se tient prêt afin de
répondre aux exigences de cette crise
sanitaire qui pourrait frapper de
manière un peu plus importants dans
certaines autres régions
merci beaucoup bertrand soubelet ancien
général de corps d'armée numéro trois de
la gendarmerie nationale merci à vous